berti ragazzi mi vedevo sul nuovissimo
video di come sia a paper doll vero deve
quello che ci stanno i mostri in giro
buona visione
adesso sentito un rumore che cosa che
sgocciola che penso la questo qua
infilarci vaso very nice vaso d'acqua
devo praticamente tornare adesso fare
tutto di ritornare a dove ho preso sto
vasetto in modo tale da rada rimetterlo
sul api sul piedistallo che adesso si
schiaccerà forte era molto fisici quanto
pensassi nota fa ci sono le cose che
trovi in giro che porco demonio non ho
capito sono collezionabili o cosa dentro
che miliardo non ha un senso
red dot tese ancora lì molto bene save
the game molto bello ragazzi un po
ansiolitico allegro essersi liberato e
poi tanto continuamente le sto coso qua
e poi scompare quando era stata scompare
ogni volta non mi ricordo dove ho preso
il vaso
se devo essere sincero era in una stanza
tipo questa qua corrector mettilo vaso
perfetto mi piace a salve
buongiorno meno male c'è gente che
almeno ciò compagnia non posso usarlo
minchia per un attimo ci fosse qualcuno
lì dietro a toni che ho trovato una
candela lido fuoco e basta che lo fa
giusto
mi scusi posso chiederle un consiglio
che lei sa più di me che cos'è questo
suo cibo alla porta se non si chiuda o
che ho capito ho capito quindi deve
esserci sempre un piedistallo ok mite io
che ne so devo avere un altro oggetto in
poche parole sono non lo posso prendere
così starò ai pezzi del vaso e sto
rumore ecco cos'era dovettero un altra
roba fare peso ma poi ma prendi
qualsiasi kucova da questo vaso qua
anche per la qualità che te ne frega
non ho capito prendi un vaso delle palle
basta che non lo so minchia random
random porca vacca totale sei veramente
una [ __ ] totalmente rantolo ragazzi ci
accomuna non so quante probabilità ci
fossero ma che culo
c'è un pettine aiuto ai tir che chiuse
c'è ancora il vaso in tutto ciò il
pettine ma cosa sa cos'è sta roba
ma cos'è mantenne perché voi valete
ma cosa sto facendo cos'è sta roba qua
va bene pettinate senza testamento
io non so niente a quanto riguarda per
quanto riguarda il loro programma
familiare a chi sono soltanto un mero
visitatore ma che cazzo me ne frega
posso andare a salvare la partita visto
che ho fatto un passaggio in più ma dove
la tua testa
no no no no giovanni no no non adesso
corri corri corri salvava titolava
perfetto non può toccarmi nessuno quando
posto libero o pettinato un morto una
statua morta perfetto che se mio hobby
sono youtuber io tutto questo ancora non
ho capito effettivamente cosa devo fare
perché il break all blacks sugar che
cacchio vele facile lo zucchero
aspettatevi però perché mi ricordo che
c'era cosa delusione però qua avrei mai
così disse a
ok ok ok più che il passo al master 5
giorni juric di questo chi scrive la
porta perfetto come nomi copiato qua
avevo visto lo zucchero bensì lo mette
lo stato
no peccato ci ho provato
c'è stato unica molto cari in taluni
voti aree è come fai
e se provassi aprire prima l'armadio che
nell'armadio non c'è una sega quindi
posso nascondermi teoricamente però devo
prendere forza la chiave questo lo posso
aprire questa via del lucchetto fisso
ciò che è scritto questo è il rosario di
mia nonna
ok sto c'è un coso una scala rotta molto
bene devo prendere questa chiave per
favore vino non rompere troppo le palle
veloci concentrarli di merda vai meno
non è la loro
sono andato o che non abbassiamo la
guardia adesso arriva controller by
ghost se ne è andato veramente che culo
era questa minchia ho trovato finalmente
ho trovato il lucchetto giusto e per
forza perché l'unico penetra selezionare
promesso 6a no perché ce ne sono
talmente tanti raja che non me li posso
ricordare due babe e vabbè se c'è
qualcuno che dovevo fare il pieno di
oggetti sicuro
minchia un mega e una chitarra e un pass
un coso figo che non faccio perfetto ho
trovato il coso per non so cosa mi serve
realtà vero per sostituire all'altro che
pesa uguale va bene però quell'altro il
volume non me lo metto nel culo che me
ne fa però vabbè
giovanna stavo facendo i cacchi miei ho
qua dentro per favore di privacy che già
è difficile sto gioco ci manca solo che
viene a rompermi le palle tu cosa me ne
fave dai vado a tornado vero che doveva
aspetta un amico della strada faceva
niente fa niente corri mi sa che la
giusta ok perfetto no perché qua mi
serve minuti delle nella stanza di prima
mannaggia il cazzo mi sono caricato in
mano a posto tutto allegro
questo gioco è un'ansia ciao a tutti lo
scheletro brutto soprattutto dopo questo
vabbé vabbé faccio da anni e basta
mi è cascata una mano serve a nessuno ok
la metti questo menti altro pezzo no
scusa non ho capito niente
ma cosa ma cosa ma qua scoso vista ma
era una bomba questo affare è una
candela vabbè ma dai ma cosa è saltato
in aria
non me l'aspettavo mai va bene torniamo
al che cacchio devo fare so io
dato lo infilo nel muro di sicuro lo
accendo lo accendo sembra vi si avvicina
qualcuno quello di quel caso sì
piuttosto esplodo e quindi allora ci
infilo questo però non lo accendo non lo
accendo adesso non è cascata sul tavolo
meno male
prendo messo ho messo la pergamena nuova
qua ok adesso lo accendo la pergamena ok
però non riesco a comprendere così mi
hanno davvero non comprendo
effettivamente
perché come si possa entrare anche se
c'è poco io non mi fido proviamo sapevo
cryans cagato in mano la vista
credo di sapere cosa devo fare basta
prendere la tela la boccia d'acqua di
prima e gliela verso soprano secondo me
è corretto o che abbiamo capito tutto
quindi ragazzi questa seconda
bisognerebbe partire dalle abili e io
che faccio lo faccio a farlo io che ne
so non ho ancora capito il prossimo sarà
l'ultimo
fatemi sapere se vi piace iscritti al
canale lasciate mi piace un commento qui
sotto
e noi ci vediamo al prossimo video come
sempre bella ragazza
[Musica]
no